welcome to this video I'm playing
Diplodocus and never played this guy
that we had and he has just a very
little amount of games played ok I'm
playing the con let's see what we get
yeah his son playing a classical set up
here when Bishop e2 yeah let's just get
stuff develop there should be three King
edge one those are the normal ways to
play that ya black ass putting some
pressure on the center yeah this is one
way to reply night a for crazy as it
looks but this is one way to play that
yeah the ideas I'm to play some Queen D
for after the caption I think Bishop d6
is a move here on hmm
56
or castles I really don't know yeah
let's let's let's do one let's start
with one thing he also has not be six
years so Queen takes I guess and now if
I've as possible
yeah I think Bishop c5 is the right way
to play this or queen c7 first I guess
yeah yeah on c4 I go to e7 and this
position I think yes try to play 96 on
night f5 to defy is playing very quickly
96 or not yeah yeah let's not think too
long and the sky is playing quickly and
I don't want to fall super far behind on
the clock um we should be for ya this is
probably worth playing ok yeah why can I
not take on me too I don't know let's
see yeah either this is one of those
people who play instantly like like pop
pop or all in signals or this is like
some long-winded analysis that want to
play Queen a five year I wonder why this
is not what so well whatever the nice
hallucination how do I get in who the
queen and to play yeah I mean you can go
rook age three but I play g6 and this is
like no attack so I don't I don't really
get what why does doing
now I mean taking twice on g6 is just
leading to nothing quite clearly I'm
taking on f2 now and isn't this okay
then he has rook g3 ok and its really
and rook be one that's not possible I
wonder what about rook f5 if I just
break this rupee one idea avoid that a
DM or queen bee six actually and then
maybe look at three
maybe this is really good yes I'm
threatening rupee one then definitely
not sure what is doing against it look
everyone aight a crook be takes f 2
because then brooke takes Queen B one is
also made g3 then I will take on f2 or I
will be one that sets both good yeah
rock be one is actually winning the
Queen rupee one would be rupee one queen
be one king g to look after winning the
Queen so I don't know what is smoothest
now look some looks tricky look be three
maybe
maybe root B 3 as a way to weigh out for
wine I can actually maybe plane Queenie
five then
yeah now we're thinking for a long time
after all those instant moves yeah rupee
three probably the only really good move
i see at the moment maybe there are
others but the only one that i see after
which i do what i can even take on e5
it's not maybe this is even the best one
Queenie five it's not it's not playing
whatsoever
or is ruby three not working and I don't
see it so that he has no move at all oh
but I don't I don't know why I what is
the deal would be three I can take it
twice of course this is of this is
coming into consideration of course
that's really really I am how much time
is he spending here like almost three
minutes now or maybe this is one of
those doorbell rang cases YCS no
movement is basically just letting the
time ran out I don't know Luke b3 seems
to be playable I mean why not
now he is somewhat disconnected or am i
disconnected no light forfeits on time
yeah we add them yeah rupee three years
the only move but we take c5 is a big
edge I would like to check this look B
takes f to us in fact the best move our
queen bee 6 is winning okay yeah I was
pretty sure that I have should have
something red but I now I see what I
missed yeah yeah you know why this is so
strong because he cannot play this check
BAM no not everyone is protected I'm
sorry but I can take him he can take him
yeah Queen B 6 is strong i was i was
thinking and i cannot play route
carefree i think this is much better
even then you get 5 and okay now this is
this is even even much easier than this
yeah but nothing group III is really the
move yeah him he has to do that then I
take him yeah and something like that is
just good for me I'm a pawn up and I
have good control like rook f1 Queen
deform yeah that's that's excellent I
really think that I mean it's it's a
very old story but I don't know why you
have to play all those super yeah
committal move so fast here just like it
White is lost in this position it's just
a losing position and it's also quite
obvious that this attack will never
really win or something after age 6 is
just a question if white is just going
down immediately or or what watch what
happens yeah yeah this was also this was
also winning I was thinking that this
are and keep missing tactics yeah yeah
but really I don't have too much
time for my own tactics training this
just winds of course yeah ok then then
this is really convincing yeah I was
more actually thinking about this move
which after Luke 23 it's maybe not yeah
I can take only five so basically every
move wins okay yeah well I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching